what happened at the dawn of our cosmos
is the missing piece needed to
understand how the universe came to be a
new experiment has failed to confirm the
observations of the so-called cosmic
dawn it's been disconfirmed and often we
think that failure is making a blunder
let's examine what that means
[Music]
cosmologists upended our view of how the
universe formed structures billions of
years ago
wait i thought that was a bicep 2
experiment right in fact didn't some guy
named keating write a book
about that whole affair called losing
the nobel prize no
the bicep 2 affair was in 2014 this new
result came from the edges experiment in
2018 four years later what is cosmic
dawn anyway well i study the cosmic
microwave background the leftover heat
from the formation of the lightest
elements on the periodic table when
hydrogen formed 380 000 years after the
big bang the universe was relatively
quiet place for perhaps millions of
years the hydrogen atoms that first
formed once they cooled down they were
able to absorb and then emit what's
called 21 centimeter radiation it's one
of the most important types of atomic
transitions known in all physics these
atoms of hydrogen can emit and absorb 21
centimeter radiation at equal rates
which made the earliest clouds in the
universe that filled our cosmos
effectively invisible but then
came the cosmic dawn
when the first stars ignited releasing
high energy ultraviolet radiation that
radiation can cause the hydrogen atoms
to transition making more absorption of
21 centimeter wavelength radiation than
they emitted when astronomers look back
to these early clouds of hydrogen
they would see
excess absorption and that would appear
as a drop in the brightness due to the
absorption at a specific highly
accurately known radio wavelength and
that would mark the time when these
first stars turned on and ignited the
universe
that's called cosmic dawn sort of the
ignition that caused the universe to
start glowing eventually those early
stars called population 3 would collapse
into black holes
the hot gas around these black holes
could generate x-rays that heat up the
hydrogen clouds and caused the
increasing rate of hydrogen emission to
increase even further we'd observe this
excess emission as an uptick an increase
in brightness at slightly shorter
wavelengths the net result would be a
dip in brightness over a very narrow
radio wavelength range
the exact wavelength of emission and
absorption would be determined by the
redshift of these hydrogen clouds this
is what was claimed by the edge's
experiment back in 2018. the redshift
goes from 21 centimeters to 400
centimeters or namely about four meters
so these are very long radio waves much
much longer than the two millimeter
wavelength of cmb photons and this is
what cosmologists had expected but
initial alarm bells were wrong when they
saw the shape and the trough of these
different absorption features were not
as expected the dip was extremely deep
and that was troubling for many
astronomers because it suggested that
the hydrogen was much colder than what
theoretical models predicted so it fell
on theoretical astronomers to come up
with conjectures as to why the universe
would have even colder hydrogen than
expected maybe there was some sort of
strange interaction between the hydrogen
and dark matter that must have filled
the cosmos back then because it fills
the cosmos today or maybe
the edges experiment
has something to do with the instrument
itself hydrogen's 21 centimeter
emissions
eventually reach earth with these long
wavelengths due to the redshift between
the emission and the absorption or
detection of these primordial radio
wavelengths now this
wavelength regime falls in the same band
that we use for radio transmission and
television broadcast
that's why edges had to be so far away
so remote in australia even more
pronounced is the emission from our
galaxy not the dusty mission that
plagued the bicep 2 experiments results
but actually emission of what's called
synchrotron radiation in our galaxy and
there's even effects from the atmosphere
that these uh radio astronomers had to
contend with it was an exquisite
measurement these astronomers were well
aware that the instrument can produce at
least as large a signal as they
predicted the question is why did it
slightly change in the area of this
trough to make it much more pronounced
why would it affect only this trough
that was measured so it fell upon
another group of astronomers to confirm
or refute these claims and as you can
guess they didn't find confirmation
contending with all these sources of
contamination so-called systematic
contamination be it from the cosmos but
not truly cosmological it could be from
our galaxy could be from the sun it
could be from some local source here on
earth or it could even be from man-made
or terrestrial interference
the edges team looked for these patterns
and they were excruciatingly exquisitely
painstaking in their search for other
explanations besides claiming a
detection of this primordial signal
which was truly groundbreaking at the
time perhaps it had something to do with
the effects of the edges of these giant
metal screens that were placed in the
ground that blocked the antenna from
seeing terrestrial emissions from the
ground the edges team modeled all the
different types of interactions and they
found still the signal persistent they
knew for certain that this type of
effect from the instrument could mimic
exactly the signal that they saw so they
want to be exquisitely precise now a
competing team trying to reproduce the
results or disconfirm the results called
saras took a completely different
experimental antenna approach they took
an entirely different design philosophy
in order to preserve the smoothness
across as many wavelength features as
possible their antenna for saras was an
aluminum cone propped up on a styrofoam
raft floated in the middle of a placid
lake
and that ensured there'd be no
reflections for more than 100 meters in
any direction it's a cool type of
approach it's a passive way of shielding
your instrument rather than having some
active or baffling use the earth and
this lake to act as a shield against
terrestrial emissions what's more
ingenious is that the slow speed of
light or radio waves in water reduces
the effect of reflections from the
bottom of the lake and the uniform
density of water made the environment
easier for these scientists to predict
and remove potential sources of
contamination when the saris team tried
and then failed to reproduce the edge's
result they saw no sign of the deep dip
at this four meter wavelength which had
been claimed now technically the saris
team ruled out the specific dip at this
precise four meter wavelength but they
didn't rule out dips at other
wavelengths that's going to be for other
teams perhaps even including the saris
team to follow up on so what to make of
these results where do we go to improve
upon them well cynthia chang who's a
radio astronomer at mcgill university in
montreal cynthia says that these two
teams were exquisitely thorough in both
calibrating which is a process that
experimentalists use to remove sources
of systematic error and how they analyze
the data
and that she's not comfortable yet
saying which is right and which is wrong
so she says the level of disagreement is
enough to make people uncomfortable from
her perspective she says it adds to the
excitement a drama in fact and luckily
she's actually leading another follow-up
experiment that's called prism that will
operate on a small island a thousand
kilometers off the coast of south africa
where terrestrial radio telescopes seek
so much interference from and that was
the main challenge for saris and for the
edges experiment but for prism she
claims it'll almost be totally absent
other experimentalists such as my friend
aaron parsons at uc berkeley who's an
expert in this field he actually claims
he thinks the sarah's null result that
this confirmation will hold up that we
haven't measured the cosmic dawn signal
it's simply perhaps too painstakingly
small for our experiments to ever detect
but
a key point which holds true not only
for edges but also for bicep is that it
stimulated growth and innovation and
attention to this important field moving
it forward he says this brings us to a
big problem though in science from my
perspective often a result from
experimentalists such as myself or my
colleagues makes a front-page headline a
big splash even appearing on tv and
sources like cnn and elsewhere and
instantly there's calls for attention
and follow-up etc etc but when there is
a retraction often it doesn't come for
months and when it does come it's not on
page one above the fold
it might be on page b17 of the saturday
edition which is the least read of all
newspaper editions so the public is
often left with the impression that the
original result holds true i've even
heard from fellow physicists that when
finding out that i was involved with
bicep say oh i heard that you guys won
the nobel prize well of course spoiler
alert my book is called losing the nobel
prize not only did i lose it but nobody
has won it for the detection of
primordial gravitational waves from the
postulated epoch of inflation so what do
you think should physicists be a little
bit more cautious in how they
communicate should they not even have
press releases press conferences
altogether let me know in the comments
and click here to find a very special
playlist that i made describing other
exquisitely sensitive ingenious
experiments seeking to determine the
nature of reality in our cosmos